joe muller is at a protest at election
headquarters but first we begin tonight
with the i-team's david charns he has
reaction out of d.c
david yeah we've been in contact with
our senators and members of congress and
we can report to you that they are safe
and they do plan to get back to work
tonight finishing what they started
there when this mob descended on the
capitol
i want to show you some video here i
just got off the phone with
congresswoman susie lee who says she was
actually in her office when
this was happening in the chamber her
colleagues here huddling
as capitol police have their guns drawn
now sources tell us
who were inside the complex that they
started receiving text messages from
police telling them to stay away from
the windows
see cover here right now congresswoman
lee remains in a lockdown awaiting a
continuation of the work she started
at one o'clock her time and here's what
she said about watching the complex get
stormed today
it was very scary because not only were
you seeing
our capitol police being overwhelmed
on tv across the street but then knowing
that there were
other uh you know instances that
were requiring some attention and you
know not
knowing if someone could possibly have
breached
the building that i was in right now
that curfew
is in effect in d.c video here right at
sundown
police trying to get a handle on those
riders you see them using strobe lights
tear gas grenades clearing those
arm protesters now like i said we have
it in contact with other representatives
in washington all day
congresswoman dina titus actually
tweeting this as she was in lockdown
lawless domestic terrorists encouraged
by the president of the united states
attempting to destroy our democracy they
will not exceed her words there
congressman stephen horsford telling us
quote this violence in chaos around the
capital is a direct result of the call
to arms by president trump
and his allies who organized and incited
today's events now president trump's
twitter actually locked for 12 hours the
company making that decision
after a series of disputed tweets about
what happened at the capitol today
and what happened in the election we did
reach out to the nevada gop about what
happened today and we have not heard
back
i'm david charns 8 news now